La Havane, souvent la Mecque des joueurs, voit
le gros lot d'un longshot politique
portant des bannières du 26 juillet, de
joyeux partisans de Fidel Castro balayent
triomphalement la capitale cubaine quelques
heures après que leur rébellion eut renversé
le régime de Fulgencio Batista. Le
26 juillet fait référence à ce jour dans  1953 lorsque
Castro a commencé sa longue lutte pour
renverser le dictateur Batista a
été une attaque armée avortée avec
Batista en fuite vers la
République dominicaine la célébration se tourne bientôt vers l'
action de la foule et le pillage des machines
à sous obtient les œufs d'autres manifestations de l'
Université de La Havane où le chef rebelle
Castro  Il a d'abord pris de l'importance, il a dirigé
des manifestations étudiantes contre le coup d'État sans effusion de sang
qui a amené Batista au pouvoir en
1952. Les touristes américains qui se trouvent être
présents lorsque l'histoire est en train de
se réfugier à l'ambassade des États-Unis, ils sont
emmenés en toute sécurité à l'aéroport
et ramenés chez eux en toute sécurité.  aux États-Unis,
des combattants rebelles fraîchement débarqués du
champ de bataille du centre de Cuba se déversent dans
la capitale pour imposer la loi martiale et
réprimer la variété des barbes un style établi
par Castro lui-même sont l'uniforme du
jour pour les rebelles
castro suit un itinéraire plus tranquille
vers La Havane quand il a commencé cette
campagne avec une poignée d'hommes il a dit que je
serai un héros  ou martyr à 31 ans c'est
vraiment un héros